an unusual site at the Kario core Market
in Dar es Salaam The Hub of Commerce in
Tanzania
on an ordinary day this is one of the
busiest markets growing Traders from
even beyond the country's borders
but since Monday Merchants here have
downed their tools they complain of
harassment from police and double
taxation for many of them a new store
Levy introduced by the government last
month was just too much
the main reason for our strike is that
we are against the new taxes which have
been introduced as a business owner I am
sure this new tax will harm our business
but also our customers that is why we
decided to come together and have a
strike against this new law because we
have already got so many taxes which we
pay
many other businesses dependent on
Commerce at the expansive Market are
also counting their losses
it's not just traders who have been
affected by this strike we as Street
vendors especially the low-income
earning group have also been affected
most of the motorbikes have just been
parked the whole day today is the third
day since the strike started we've
really been affected
such public displays of dissatisfaction
with the government are uncommon in
Tanzania
since coming to power two years ago
president Sulu Hassan has been praised
for gradually opening up freedoms not
enjoyed under her predecessor
striking Traders now have the
government's attention
the Prime Minister on Wednesday paused
implementation of the new store Levy and
called for further talks the Striking
Traders have now been urged to resume
business with the promise of having
their concerns addressed
Al Jazeera